Lily is just started walking oh I'm in
the thick of it Meghan markle's daughter
lillibet celebrates a milestone it is so
much work to be a mom when you are just
trying to be a conscious parent to raise
good kind human beings while chatting on
her podcast archetypes The Duchess of
Sussex shares updates about her little
ones as she offers support for moms
everywhere you can be the mom who says
she needs a break for just a minute and
then if you're like me sits in bed
scrolling through pictures of you
guessed it your kids
Megan and Prince Harry are parents to
son Archie and their 17 month old
daughter well they've chosen lillybet
which is the nickname that was given to
the queen when she was a little girl so
it's deeply personal and really an
incredibly intimate name for the queen
but the couple have made it clear that
they will refer to her and they expect
others to refer to her as Lily
and as the former actress reveals Lily's
grown up fast Lily is just started
walking she's a year and a couple months
old and Archie's just over three years
old yeah she even has a go-to term for
having two kids under four years old
toddling oh I'm in the thick of it yeah
toddling and to paint the picture Megan
breaks down her morning routine I'm sure
it'll only get more chaotic as they get
older but for me it's
you know both monitors on for the kids
to hear them always up with Lily get her
downstairs then a half hour later
Archie's up start doing his lunchbox my
husband's helping me get him downstairs
and it's I make breakfast for all three
of them it's very important to me I love
doing it uh that's so sweet and it's
just if to me feels like the greatest
way to start the morning and later the
Pod becomes a family affair with a sweet
Cameo from Mom Doria oh sugar my mom's
FaceTiming me hey Mommy
hey
that's my girl I'm okay I'm hanging in
there it's okay I'm recording right now
do you want to see
hi we're we're just doing some
podcasting can I call you back in a
little bit yeah you have on the smiley
face I have on a smiley face I love you
yeah
as Megan tells it she admires her mother
even more after becoming a mama herself
and then with this episode on my brain
it got me thinking about all the ways my
mom supported me how she took care of me
and the house and herself and
how she just juggled so much
the amount that women carry that they
navigate its immense and it's often
the most thankless
unpaid labor there is at home women just
work really really hard
[Music]